today we are going to be going over some
some basic sorting algorithms simply
case so you have a list of numbers and
you want to sort that into numerical
order and there's all sorts of reasons
you want to do that say you've got a
spreadsheet open and you want to sort
one column that use a sorting algorithm
but also there's the less obvious
applications all sorts of artificial
intelligent stuff if you're playing a
computer game and there's some sort of
AI somewhere there will be somewhere
that they'll definitely using sorting to
find the best way to go about doing
something let me explain how bubble sort
works it's got some playing cards here
so I'll just tell you I'll deal them out
upside down so I can't see hopefully
won't come out sorted so we've got five
three seven eight okay so this is
actually quite a boring bubble sort you
go through the list you compare each
pair of elements in turn and if you need
to swap them you swap them so you need
to swap three and five yes because three
is lower than five okay so we swapped
those over then we look at five and
seven
- we've swapped those there we don't
seven and eight three sort those no we
don't let me go back to start based and
Tweenies swap three and five no five and
seven no seven and eight
no that was very simple very easy once
we've gone through the list one full
time and there's no swaps we know the
list must be sorted so I'll show you
that with a few more cards
okay so let's deal out three four five
six seven eight cards okay so we start
from the left do we need to swap seven
and three yes
doing you swap seven and ten no do we
need to swap ten six yes ten four yes
ten and eight yes ten and five yes ten
and seven yes okay let me go back to the
start to need to stop three and seven
no seven or six yes seven or four yes
seven and eight no eight and five yes
eight and seven yes eight and ten no
that's the start
three and six no six and four yes
six and seven no 7:05 yes seven or 7 no
8 and 7 no 8 and 10 no practical start 3
and 4 no 4 and 6 no 6 and 5 yes 6 and 7
no 6 and 7 no 7 and 8 no 8 and 10 No
back to start three and four no four and
five no five and six no six and seven no
seven seven no seven and eight no eight
and ten
No so we've sorted the list I took a lot
of effort and if you had even more cars
it would take even longer you can't
actually make bubble sauce slightly
simpler so let me just do a quick first
pass over this so swap those don't swap
those that's all those dents all those
don't stop those do swap those do swap
those what you do now is after every
pass the highest card will definitely
have been swapped all the way to the end
so actually you don't need to check that
one anymore you can move that off and
just go right don't stop those no those
no those no those no those no those yes
okay so now you know eight is actually
the next card there but it's still not a
very good algorithm I can demonstrate
merge sort to you if you like so for
that I have got another prop we bring in
this so I'll deal out seven cards the
merge sort we split the list into two
parts okay so we've got this left half
goes there and the right half goes there
we've got two lists now this list gets
put into to this let's guess listen to
two and then each of these four lists
gets put into two until you've got
either one card or or no cards in your
list now what we do we look at each of
these pairs of sorted lists and we merge
them back together in the right order by
looking at the top card on each list
first of all we put four and then we put
seven okay so now we've that's a sorted
list there okay so with ten and eight we
look at the lowest card put that in
first we've got eight then we've got ten
and then this one we've got five and
then we've got seven but these two we've
got three and the empty list so three
just goes there hopefully everyone will
agree that a list with just one card in
it is sorted I've separated them just a
clarity so you can see the cards you
should only bear to look at the top
element at each list so now what we do
we merge these two sub lists part
together which is the lowest card
between four and eight those are the two
we can see so we pick four I goes in
that list and then we say which is
lowest between seven and eight it's
seven which is lowest between eight and
nothing it's eight and then similarly
ten and nothing it's ten and then look
at these two lists we take pick the
lowest so we've got three and then got
an empty list so we just put five there
and seven there so we've got two so
to lists now and all we do is merge them
back together so we've got four here and
three here so threes lowest so that goes
first between 4 & 5 5 & 7 & 7 7 & 7 8 7
8 and nothing it's 8 and then between 10
nothing it's 10 I did three tests we've
got bubble sorts we've got the slightly
better bubble sort which is the one
where you check less elements each time
because you know the highest ones are
already sorted so we can see that
actually around the low end
mergesort can be significantly slower
than either bubble sorts and that's
because most thoughts got slightly more
overhead associated with it and also I
guess the lists are more likely to be
sorted or nearer sorted when they're
smaller so we've got the input size here
so I sorted 10 things in this row I run
it a thousand times for each so a
thousand different randomly sorted lists
so it took three hundred ninety one
ninety seconds sort 10 things with the
first bubble sort
322 with the second bubble sort and 770
with merge sort
even though merge sort should be quicker
there's going to be a little bit of
overheads it's a slightly more
complicated sorting algorithm however as
the input size gets bigger if we're get
to 100 say bubble sort to twenty eight
thousand nine eight seconds the better
bubble sort took nineteen microseconds
and know sort took about eight
microseconds so you can see there that
the merge sort Saul ready starting to
take over even by 100 so let's see what
it's like at a thousand bubble sort is
taking three milliseconds to sort this
of a thousand things the better bubble
sort to take in two milliseconds and
merge sort is taking 0.1 of a
millisecond to sort the list with a
small end it doesn't remake with
difference but with a big end makes it
makes a world of difference really
important okay so at five thousand it
was taking seventy seven milliseconds to
sort with double sort 51 milliseconds
sort of the better level sort point six
five the millisecond to do those sort
bubble sort as I said earlier scales
with the square of the input size so
they're going to call the emphasize n so
we can say bubble sort scales with N
squared
merge sort that we've just done that
scales with the input size times the log
of the input size a log is it's just the
inverse of a power
if you've got 10 to the power of 3 say
is a thousand log base 10 of thousands 3
whatever the base of the log is it just
is just a constant factor in front of it
and that doesn't matter
motor sort will always take n Times log
n runtime so in the best case and the
worst case and the average case you've
always got to split the list into two
and into two again and two again and
then you still want to compare them all
immersion about together so that one
that one that one that one so you've
kind of always got to do the same number
of steps the best case of merge sort is
still n log n whereas bubble sort what
actually what you'll find is if you've
got a list that's already sorted it will
only take n steps to do it
because all it's doing is goes doing
sort these no don't need to top these no
don't need to sort these no okay so
you've done basically n steps so it's
proportional to number of cards don't is
duty swap so you're done but if you want
to sort a list with a million things in
bubble sorts not the way to go
you need to better succinctly convey how
when I wear them scales there's some
mathematical notation used by computer
scientists this is called Big O notation
so actually what you might find is your
actual algorithm might run in N squared
plus 4n plus tens but what you don't
write you don't write N squared plus 4n
plus ten you can just chuck away the
lower order terms so you just take the
term the scales biggest so you can cross
off those and you just say as o of N
squared okay and the reason is as you
increase n the N squared term will
always dominate for n so if n is 1 we
get 1 squared which is 1 plus 4 times 1
which is 4 plus 10 so you can see this
term is actually the biggest one and
then this term is biggest and then the N
squared times smallest but if n is 2 you
get 2 squared which is 4 you get 2 times
4 which is 8 and then we still got 10
but if we make n 10 you get 10 squared
here which is 100 we get 4 times 10
which is 40 and then we've got 10 here
but as n gets bigger the N squared term
it dominates the rest of it the N
squared term really takes takes
precedence over the others with Big O we
only care about the highest order term
so N squared so is it a way of saying
there is
stuff that goes along there might be
other stuff but it's a way of
simplifying it when we're looking at the
figures from my tests or and you know
merge sort of it's slower actually at
the start than bubble sort that's
probably because there's some big
constant factors in there or some
overhead that is making it take longer
there are some algorithms that scale the
order of n factorial is n times n minus
1 times n minus 2 times all the way down
to one got N and n factorial n is one n
factorials one n is two it's two it's
three we've got three times two times
one which is six when it's four we've
got six six six six 720 but seven it's
whatever seven times by it is quite a
big number by the time you get to 70
factorial my calculator doesn't like it
because you've gone over ten to the
power of 100 I can show you a sorting
algorithm that in the average case is n
factorial if you like so we've got some
cards you throw them up into the air and
pick them up we check if they're sorted
so are they sorted no right so so chuck
them up in the air again and once more
pick them up are they sorted no we could
be here forever but in the average case
it's the factorial of the number of
cards so we've got seven cards here so
let's go it's going to take me a long
time
called BOGO salt by the way interesting
though BOGO sort has got a best-case
complexity of n because if the list is
sorted you check if it's sorted and
these so you finished you've only done n
steps there's anything that you know
I've used bogus sorting and practical I
don't think so I think the term was
invented just to just as just the sort
of instructive purposes so you can kind
of have an example of an N factorial
algorithm I mean you'll find it in
practice quite difficult to write any
algorithm that runs an N factorial it's
difficult even if you're a really bad
programmer you'd struggle you probably
ought to be quite good programmer to
work out how to do something that runs
it runs that badly